[Musica]
torri radio da tanti anni e ti emozioni
per tutto ancora si me la sto facendo
addosso allora ragazzi
partiamo con ordine io ho un discorso
che mi sono preparata ho una memoria
pessima ma l'ho studiato da tre giorni
ringrazio mio marito per aver avuto la
pazienza di assistermi in queste ultime
ore io sono valentina ricci e mai dico
mai avrei immaginato di essere qui ora
come molto spesso mi accade nella vita
mi trovo in dei luoghi e dei momenti
così assurdi così spettacolari così
inaspettati che dici ma come cazzo o
falso mi è capitato con la radio mi è
capitato quando scritto un romanzo né
capitato qualche grado visto sposata
cioè la sensazione è sempre la stessa ma
può ma forse per capire perché mi
succede così bisogna fare un passo
indietro
non sono mai stata una bambina sicura di
sé
ma
neanche qui ragazzi anche e soprattutto
perché dici i miei mi vestono da
principessa di primavera ma toglimi quel
cappello di lana sotto il cappello vero
ma perché mi devi far vergognare
comunque non sono mai stata sicura di
meno non sono una quella che si
immaginava quando era bambina che da
grande avrebbe fatto non sapevo sognare
ho sempre invidiato i calciatori le
ballerine gli scienziati e divulgatori
io pensavo di non aver nessun tipo di
talento la mia ambizione maggiore era
quella di diventare cartolaia solo per
il fatto di avere a disposizione diario
quaderno animati te prima di tutti per
cui l'unico tale talento che mi sono
sempre riconosciuta e quello di avevo i
quadernoni più belli di tutti cioè
campionessa di copertine di quadernoni
non forse non bastava nella vita con
tutto che nella mia famiglia ho avuto
esempi di eccellenza cioè esempi di
gente che si è fatta un gran mazzo se
l'è fatto da sola e c'è riuscita volevo
partire salutando mio papà che
sicuramente ci sta seguendo nonostante
sia legato con i collegamenti internet
massa che ce l'ha fatta lui e peppe
giuseppe ricci peppuccio è nato a pesaro
quindi qua vicino è nato in provincia
molto spesso la provincia ti abbraccia
in un in un caldo abbraccio che però a
volte potrebbe essere anche risultare
anche un po soffocante mio papà aveva
l'ambizione di andare a lavorare in una
grande azienda di fare carriera e quindi
a un certo punto della sua vita molto
giovane partito per milano da solo
milano è una città molto grande che
offre tante possibilità milano la città
con gli occhi grandi che però molto
spesso non vede le cose piccole non
riconosce le singole storie quindi ha
vissuto anni di solitudine di sacrifici
lontano da casa però ragazzi ce l'ha
fatta e quindi grande peppuccio mia
madre è una guerriera
questo mi commuovo
lei ragazzi è la persona più coraggiosa
del mondo non ha paura di niente
mia madre non ha una cartella clinica un
enciclopedia treccani ma non l'ho mai
sentita dire no basta non ce la faccio
più mollo colpo cia paura è una gran
[ __ ] per la quale vi chiedo un
grandissimo applauso
oppure lo zio cantante io ho uno zio che
è stato il primo a cantare davanti a
papa giovanni paolo ii lui 9 san remy
all'attivo lo julio iglesias italiano lo
chiamavano arrivava da palermo è
arrivato a milano famiglia proletaria
che faceva fatica ad andare avanti si è
rimboccato le maniche e ce l'ha fatta da
solo con le sue mani e davanti a tutti
questi
questi racconti ma motivazionali con i
quali sono cresciuta io le mie mani lo
utilizzavo solo unicamente per farmi le
canne per dire le faceva molto bene le
rollava molto bene e mentre fumavo
dicevo sticazzi qualcosa farò anch'io a
un certo punto no
crescendo la mia attitudine a non sapere
cosa fare della vita è andata via via
peggiorando
fatto il liceo per sei anni mi sono
iscritto all'università per tre poi
mollato tra l'altro i miei mi ricordano
ancora che ho lasciato ho dichiarato
loro che avrei lasciato l'università il
25 di dicembre di qualche anno fa
avevano appena pagato la rata va bene
per l'anno a venire però errori di
gioventù sta di fatto che la vita sa
essere molto spiritosa e un giorno mi è
arrivata una chiamata da radio deejay
che sta in via massena 2 e sapevo
benissimo dove sta via massena due
perché sta vicino a vivo pili la via
nella quale andava farmi le canne e
quindi c'è ci sono arrivata facile
facile sono entrata sono stata convocata
da un'amica di un amica di mio fratello
che cercava una persona che
sbobinato la segreteria telefonica nella
quale gli ascoltatori mandavano i
messaggi per prenotarsi a un programma
di albertino lavoro facile detto vabbè
ce la posso fare entrò a radio deejay e
vengo illuminata da quel fascio di luce
che ha illuminato john belushi i blues
brothers quando si rende conto che
l'unico modo per salvare l'orfanotrofio
è riunire la banda cioè io entro è la
banda radio dice io mi trovo in questo
posto in questo momento ma ragazzi ma io
voglio restare qua tutta la vita tutta
la vita non lo so sono 22 anni che sono
lì e quel momento in quel momento ho
capito quello che poi è diventata la mia
passione io da grande ho capito cosa
volevo fare da grande la radio è ogni
giorno da 22 anni a questa parte ogni ma
ogni giorno che viene acceso il
microfono
tutto il resto non esiste esiste solo il
qui e ora
dicevamo che la vita sa essere molto
spiritosa e sa essere anche molto
stronza come lo è stata non più che con
altri e lo è un po con tutti e succedono
a quei giorni in cui non c'è voglia di
far niente io quando sto male sarebbe
immobile a letto simulando la morte tipo
un opossum ma potrei sbagliarmi
piangendo su me lamentando i miei
fallimenti alle ingiustizie
poi però succede tutti i giorni che si
accende quel microfono e in quel momento
tu sei qui e ora e non sei solo tu la
magia della radio proprio questa il qui
e ora non riguarda un'unica persona e
che ora è una straordinaria alchimia di
di storie di voci di colori di odori
anche se siamo in radio di odori e
questa la roba che lo rende un lavoro
meraviglioso ed è questo il concetto che
io ho cercato di applicare alla mia vita
ho passato un sacco di tempo pensando di
stare conducendo una vita piena di
fallimenti un po di tempo fa avevo
incontrato una mia amica di vecchissima
data con la quale avevo condiviso i 14
15 anni non ci vedevamo da una cifra di
tempo e quando ci siamo viste le metro a
e raccontami cosa hai fatto in tutto
questo tempo e io mi sono trovata dire
guardate non ha finito l'università e
non mi sono sposata non ha avuto figli
cioè ho raccontato la mia vita come un
inanellarsi di robero rende ma a me non
e mica solo quello e lì però quel
momento che mi è servito perché ho
capito che fino a quel momento io avevo
cercato di costruirmi un futuro che non
era quello che volevo io ma pensavo che
quel lì imposto forse l'unico futuro
possibile l'unico futuro che potesse
raccontarmi come persona soprattutto
come donna se posso permettermi
e quindi ciao sono valentina ho 44 anni
non ho fatto la cartolaia non mi sono
laureata mi sono sposata questo sì
non ho figli forse non ne avrò mai non
so ma sono felice e sono felice perché
ho capito che io non voglio vivere nel
futuro il futuro è un sogno può essere
un incubo ma il tempo in cui voglio
vivere è il presente il cui è l'ora il
presente il tempo che voglio coniugare
come verbo il presente è l'unica
ambizione che voglia avere e quindi
salutandovi vi dico ciao sono valentina
ho 44 anni lavora alla radio
amo lele e mi faccio un culo così per
essere felice e tutti i giorni qui e ora
grazie
[Musica]